you know what I can't do it I'm not
really gonna badly I don't do that sort
of thing
are you shakin I do work at a dispensary
though now you're kind of looking down
this way you won't look at me even
though you have glasses on why I'm Jim
Huerta's former law enforcement 12 years
today I'm gonna see who's stoned so
motley looking crew
how about you first what's your name
destiny
have a seat please nice to meet you you
having a good day
I am I'm having a great day when was the
last time you ate
oh god lunch time so probably new I know
I'm like what time is it
yeah that's okay what do you do for fun
when I am not busy I like to walk my dog
I enjoy spin classes it's kind of fun
art it's fun
no young people thinks going to things I
don't know what that is I don't know
well that's all people things too okay
well you know all people think ah
perfect okay I don't need any more
questions okay thank you how much you
sir good what's your name Jeff Jeff nice
to meet you nice to meet you as well
you do for a living Jeff I work here at
BuzzFeed oh you do
last time you ate it was yeah I was like
right when you asked that question
really I was like and what do you do for
fun play basketball say beach volleyball
since we're out here now and then just
binge watch TV shows when I can gotcha
you say out here now we're different so
I'm from Indiana and take your glass off
let me see your eyes okay man hobble and
me alright Jeff thank you appreciate it
how about you in your name
Irene nice to meet you have a seat do
you live here I live are centrally and
how long have you lived there oh the
whole thing you ever travel yeah yeah it
does where do you travel to I've been to
New York Kentucky Florida Alaska alright
no we're out of the country though no
not yet when did you last eat just about
what did you eat there was a bunch of
different things and toppings I she was
from Holland was good yeah yeah I think
that's good yeah sure
how about you sir in your name Brendan
Brendan nice to meet you hands are cold
Brendan oh yeah I got cold hands cold
feet all day long cold and cold feet
that's me you nervous
no no not sitting across from a cop
doesn't make you nervous I haven't
your mouth dried about no no y-you
licking your lips and your teeth of a
chapped lips oh well you know that makes
them even more chapped the more you lick
them know that really does yeah I've
learned something you're licking your
teeth more than you're looking your lips
that's high hyper specific and now
you're kind of looking down this way you
won't look at me even though you have
glasses on why it's all a ruse it's all
a ruse you're trying to trick me I'm
working yeah you're working me hard
yeah all right when did you last eat I
don't care any last day I truly don't
care it's just something to get you to
talk you like this you can't stick your
tongue out further than that okay
perfect what did you eat two packages of
Ritz peanut butter crackers which you're
almost making this women real easy
almost making it really easy how'd you
get to work today I drove do you work
here I do okay perfect what's your
favorite way of getting high I don't do
that sort of thing okay not at all it's
leaked on the state yeah I mean it's you
know it's just not my cup it's not your
cup of tea I think I'm good thanks how
would I have you come back down for a
second you don't mind you know you just
stick your tongue out for me that says I
can't go farther and how did you get to
work - you drove - and you work here -
don't you know what I'm gonna do like
your nails thank you very nice you know
it comes in too little it does come in -
you - cookies and gummy bears high
praise cornflakes brownies not that I do
it though no not that you do it I do
work at a dispensary though uh-huh
anything else you want tell me yeah cuz
you're offering up a lot of information
I didn't ask about you can go back one
more time destiny come see me can you
stick your tongue out for me I can't and
how about you your hands it says you
have nice and Hills - thank you I don't
you can do my nails for me I think that
would be unacceptable my line of work
anywhere
how'd you get to work today I drove you
drove I did how long have you worked
here almost a year you enjoy it I love
it okay I'm done oh I just want to know
more about you okay one more time Jeff
were you just standing out there by
yourself you stick your tongue out for
me how would you answer that you have
ugly nails like me yeah
why you she hmm are you shaking yeah I
noticed that too I always shake I've
noticed that dear yeah you're gonna tell
me who's high right that way that we can
snitch either not a snitch and I'll get
you fired can you do me a favor
yeah can you stand up for me yeah now
just right there's fine what you put
your feet together heels and toes like
this and it's down at your side okay and
what you stay there okay I'm gonna ask
you to perform a one leg stand I'm gonna
have you point your foot your toe go
ahead and look at my foot point your toe
look at you oh and count one one
thousand two one thousand three one
thousand four one thousand and continue
on until I tell you to stop feet
together heels and toes hands on your
side stare at your toe you may begin
[Music]
can you point your toe though as you're
doing it there you go no just keep
that's good yeah you're fine how about
you you understand the instructions feet
see other heels and toes hands on your
side you're gonna raise your foot
whichever one you want I don't care
point your toe look down at your toe and
count one one thousand two one thousand
three one thousand four one thousand and
so on it's a time to maneuver I'll tell
you when to stop you may begin you know
what I can't do it I'm not really good
and badly oh you're not gonna I'm really
not okay okay well one I remember hands
at your side look at your toe though
look at your top one thousand five one
thousand six one thousand seven one
thousand
with over 9,000 10,000 you just want us
out there it's perfect
thank you all right I think I've seen
enough gathered enough evidence and Mike
pick four who's stoned is Irene Jeff it
was those damn shakes honestly I am a
shaker though I thought that was gonna
like be a tell but like that is just me
take your glasses off for you come on
out could you still tell what the guys
who came without Wow can you tell I
should exactly man oh yeah you should go
play poker well yeah your eyes are dark
your color your eyes are dark so I
really can't tell unless I get up close
the process for doing all this would
have been more more human you know that
what we call the stupid human tricks or
whatever you want to call them but if I
was doing this in the field I take your
blood pressure I'd take your body
temperature look in your eyes and look
at the size of your eyes and darkness
compared to light a little hobble here
when you're wearing glasses because you
you do understand have you ever been
arrested know if you get arrested and
you're dealing with a cough like this
yeah the glasses come off you know
you'll get to sit down believe it but
now you tricked me
you got me good appreciate it I've made
me look like a fool Jeff no I can be
wrong see that was my first time doing
that I have anxiety so that's why I how
do you have my you failed that test yeah
I know right credibly you failed that
test you didn't follow instructions you
couldn't keep your balance it's pretty
easy I mean people would say well I
can't keep my balance why I've got
normally you're go 30 extra pounds of I
know not so good you trick me and then
your tongue your tongue has it looks
like you smoked
I had some candy here you don't smoke
cigarettes no mmm interesting okay well
again I was hobble buddy by the glasses
so I'm just gonna use that as my excuse
if there's cover
five it does it does you know the the
the eyes are the windows to everything I
mean I was nervous approving your
uniform but other than that I'm good
they'll get nervous with the uniform all
right I put it on this morning it's good
me Fancher I see you guys all the time
it's like you guys we're over practice
over there or something all right thank
you sorry for falsely picking me as you
can tell we all make mistakes don't you
dress
[Music]